We'll start by adding
our callback functions
to our ForecastFragment.
Now know we have
two different options here
for loader callbacks.
We want to make sure we're choosing
the android.support.v4 callback
so we're compatible with Gingerbread.
These take generic type.
We're going to want to use Cursor.
And yes, that is andriod.database.cursor.
Now, let's move down to where
we want to actually insert this code.
Here at the bottom, and of course,
we use CTRL+I to actually insert.
And there we have it beautifully,
our loader pattern with cursor.
Now, let's do some work
that will help us out.
First we're going to add
an array of columns
to the top of our ForecastFragment.
These are the columns that are going
to be used in our query.
Note, that since both
WeatherEntry and LocationEntry
have the underscore ID field,
we must fully qualify
which ID we want in our projection
for this query to work.
And in fact this query requires
a projection to work at all,
otherwise [inaudible].
Next, here are indices
that are tied to these columns.
This will make some
of our work easier, later on.
Note, that these actually must match.
Then we create some public indices
for us to use in our adapter.
This allows us to make our code
tiny and efficient in the adapter,
but it means we must
maintain the relationship
between these column indices
and the projection.
Each loader has an ID.
It allows a fragment to have
multiple loaders active at once.
We're goint to place this,
along with an instance variable
to stave off our location here
at the top of our class.
Next we're going to override
onActivityCreated.
Loaders are initialized
in onActivity Created
because their lifecycle
is actually bound to the activity
not the fragment.
Note the use of the loader ID:
FORECAST_LOADER.
Then we return
to the onCreateLoader function.
We add a new CursorLoader.
This CursorLoader has our query,
including start date,
columns, and sort order.
Our start date is actually in our URI.
Our columns are the ones
we defined earlier.
And our sort order is going to be based
upon COLUMN_DATETEXT ascending ("ASC").
Let's do one last check.
We want to make sure we're using
the support library version
of all of these classes,
otherwise we won't get
Android 2.3 compatibility.